okay so starting okay so I there are two
more slides that I didn't get to last
last lecture that I really want to
because that's a cute story for that as
well plus these details are necessary to
go from a suffix array to a suffix tree
and to do other algorithms with suffix
arrays instead of suffix trees so this
additional array which I mentioned I
named before is called the LCP array
stands for longest common prefix and in
order to get to it will define H of K
visually this will be a lot easier after
anyway hok is the length of the longest
common prefix of Suffolk's k so we know
what a suffix k is inside the string and
some other suffix which saw their suffix
it's the suffix that is named just
before k in the suffix array okay so let
me here's the suffix array okay and if I
want to know I the height of let's say
eight okay I want to know what is the
length of the longest common prefix of
suffolk's eight that's my k and the
suffix that's located one position
before k in the suffix array which is 11
all right so eight and 11 again I
mentioned that even though we would do
work the actual algorithm to be on the
suffix array it's really useful
conceptually to look at the suffix tree
so eight and 11 here's 11 where is eight
take off my glasses I can see it yeah
there and the length of the longest
common substring the prefix of the
suffix k and the suffix located so eight
and eleven that's length 1 and so eight
and you look down here but these are
actually the H values age of eight is
one okay i confuse everybody enough so
another way of thinking about this is
remember how I told you you can get the
suffix array from a suffix tree you just
do a lexicographic depth-first traversal
of the suffix tree and you'll pick up
the suffix array so two consecutive
entries in the suffix array are the two
consecutive leaves that are visited in
that depth first traversal so we have
the step first reversal remembers
lexicographic so you visit 11 and then
the next one you visit is 8 and that's
why 11 and 8 our neighbors okay and
there the longest substring that begins
common substring that begins at position
8 and also position 11 is the string
that that you read on the walk down to
that node there the lowest common
ancestor in the suffix tree of those two
leaves to leave eight relief 11 okay all
right so say it another way I'm going to
say this two or three times because it's
the key thing if you have the suffix
tree we get a suffix array 4am it by
doing a lexicographic depth-first
traversal and when you're doing that
traversal you come down to a a leaf 9
and you walk up to some point where you
start going down again at that point
that is the longest as the substring
that begins at that position nine and
also at the next position you're going
to run into which is 10 that's the
longest substring that's common to both
of those and the depth down there is
that length everybody clear on that so
in other ways things is if for each
consecutive entry in the suffix array I
also told you on the suffix tree what
their least common ancestor was what
node is common to both of them and as
low as possible that's the information
where we want okay and it's encoded in
this H and then if I organize the h's eh
values underneath the
corresponding entry that's called the
LCP array okay but I like to think of it
as the H value okay so if I'm given K
like for I know I'm beating this to
death but k is equal to for its
predecessor in the suffix array is seven
why is it seven because in the
lexicographic depth-first search we went
to seven and the next thing we went to
was four and here is where we move from
going back up to where we start going
down again so this is the longest
substring that's common to the substring
starting at seven and the substring
starting at four and that depth is too
and so seven is it for there's the two
underneath it okay all right if you have
the suffix array and you have the LCP
array or you have the H values you can
build the suffix tree you just sort of
think in reverse of what I was just
telling you okay because this is it's
telling you for every success of each
neighboring pair of indices how far up
we get aware to their where does their
agreements stop and anyway you is a
homework exercise you can devise a
linear time algorithm to use this
information and to reconstruct the
suffix tree and what i advertised
earlier was that every fancy algorithm
or cute linear time algorithm that's
known for suffix trees has been
implemented now in suffix arrays and LCP
if you have those two pieces and what's
the what's the not conspire can actually
call it constructive what's the simplest
proof of that is that well you could
obviously take the suffix array on the
LCP and build the suffix tree which is
just said you could do in linear time
and then from there run the algorithm on
Suffolk streets but consistent with the
goal of building a suffix array without
building a suffix tree and therefore in
smaller space
we want to only run those algorithms on
these two and we also want to build the
LCP in linear time given the suffix
array and given the string so we don't
want even though I defined it in terms
of the suffix tree is visually clearer I
want to be able to find this array or
another way of saying it I want to find
these H values without having the suffix
tree okay so this is an open goal for
many years and just as as the question
of finding a suffix array without
building a suffix tree was open for many
years but it turns out that there is a
linear time algorithm for this which i'm
going to show you and it really is a
just a twiddle on the two fingered
approach so if I so hand it but it I had
11 an age or something okay so here's
position 11 here's position 8 and I want
to know what is the length of the
longest substring that begins at eight
and begins at eleven that are identical
well the obvious way to do that is with
these two fingers you compare the
character at eight and eleven if they're
equal you move over and compare nine and
twelve and if they're equal you move
over you keep moving over until you find
one that's not equal and there you have
h of 11 okay so just you know if this
was a a X and this is a a B then doing
that age of 11 would be equal to 2 okay
so but we have a linear number of with
end pairs that we would do this for and
even though this is a small match in
this little example it could be
something proportional to the length and
so that would be something that's all we
can prove about it that is N squared in
fact
could make up examples which stated on
squared in that in that example but so
that's that's the obvious algorithm it
works I mean everybody recognize that
it's it works but it doesn't let a
linear time now I'm going to add a
little twiddle to that algorithm that's
going to make it running on your time
okay and it's it's this idea okay so
we're going to we're going to compute H
1 H 2 i'm actually eight no kh3 so h 1
i'm about to say no we don't need one
but one could be somewhere in the middle
here of the suffix array and then its
neighbor could be like 26 or something
okay so we're going to compute these H
values in where this index is increasing
okay so we're going to in terms of the
two fingered approach it's this one and
then whatever what is its predecessor 26
and etc and then then 42 and whatever
its predecessor was and so on and so the
left finger is moving over by one at
each time or it's moving left that's
moving right after each iteration the
right finger jumps all over the place
because it depends on on what the
predecessor in the suffix array was okay
but here's the key the key idea if it's
written here suppose we computed HK now
HK could either be 0 which means that
there's no agreement between those two
substrings that we're looking at in
which case we just the next thing we do
is back to our two fingers at position k
plus 1 but if it happens to be something
bigger than 1 then when we want to
compute the next one HK plus 1 we can
skip over h minus 1 characters before we
start character comparisons again ok and
see the picture picture on the right up
here I got a little bit rushed
so again think of it in terms of suffix
trees even though we're not going to
actually be on suffix trees so here's k
and its predecessor in the suffix array
let's say is j because again it's it's
this lexicographic depth-first traversal
UJ and then you come back and you get k
so in the suffix array we have j and its
predecessor we have K and its
predecessor is J and here's it's it's
this this is depth H
that's the picture we're looking at H of
k is equal to little H which is bigger
than one and I claim that then when we
look at k plus 1 didn't play in my space
will this is a suffix array here's k and
its previous its predecessor is j now
where's k plus 1 we don't know i mean
it's in the race somewhere but it I'm
not saying it's anywhere close to this
and what is its predecessor we don't
know that either ok good answer
everybody got that right there's nobody
yeah so I'll just call that J Prime ok
and we don't know any relationship with
j prime to j ok ok so we have that but
one thing we do know is a relationship
between k plus 1 that's one of the
things we want to understand and J plus
1 ok now this is not what we want want
Jay crime but here's j and j plus 1 is
here sorry that was in suffix array yeah
now I want to show you the string this
is s here is K and again we don't know
where j is it was the predecessor in the
suffix right but in terms of s it could
be anywhere let's say it's just
pictorially there okay we know that the
length of the longest common substring
the sorts of k and the substituting
starts at j that's h that's length H
that's what we what we learn here NH is
bigger than one so what is the length of
the longest substring that starts at j
plus 1 and k plus 1 was H minus 1 okay
it's exactly h minus 1 so and the keep
so between k plus 1 and J plus 1 this is
length H minus 1 okay now we're in this
picture this is the punch line we're in
this picture is j prime okay j prime
remember is the predecessor of k plus 1
in the suffix array so cape j prime is
the leaf that you visit before you visit
k plus 1 leave k plus 1 okay it is you
remember to get the suffix of regular
doing a lexicographic depth-first
traversal so j prime is and and this
remember is the the least common
ancestor of k plus 1 and j prime
but this is a common ancestor of it so J
prime is going to be down here okay and
this is going to be above this point
because this is a common ancestor of
both J Prime and K + 1 picture tells
everything is it everybody get it hey
wey y minus J Prime I mean SJ plus 1 and
that's esta noche prime um okay so yeah
so we really want this this is what we
want and we already have J&K in J&K that
goes down h okay and so I know that J
plus 1 and k plus 1 is going to be h
minus 1 all right now
so what J prime is the
the leaf you visit in your lexicographic
depth-first traversal just before you
visit k plus 1 okay so where is j plus 1
in this picture I claim it's above here
not down in here okay what would happen
if J plus 1 was in here okay but what
happened is j plus 1 was in there then
remember our depth our Luck's graphic
Kepler severstal goes this way to j
prime and that comes up and
lexicographically comes down to k plus 1
is what we know
oh yeah but then the length the common
length between J plus 1 and k plus 1
that common length would be bigger than
H minus 1 and we know that the common
substrings from J and K were greater
than 1 greater than 0 very legal one a
greater than one so this has to be equal
AAA here a here so if if j plus 1 was
down here then the agreement between j
plus 1 and k plus 1 is bigger than h
minus 1 and then you add on the two
characters at the left position J in the
position K which are equal and therefore
you get an a substring starting at j &
substring starting at k which is longer
than h there which is a contradiction so
does that make sense okay 11 yes one
maybe okay so yeah that's a good point I
really have to say and I did rigorously
that J plus 1 is up here is above the
least common ancestor of J Prime and K +
1 and this is what we want so the
conclusion here is that H of k plus 1
can skip over H minus 1 characters
before we start doing this naive
comparison again so I've just computed
the length of the longest one from k and
j and that was h and now i want k plus 1
and wherever j prime is ok but what I'm
saying here is this can skip over
instead of doing my two fingers from k
and j prime i can skip over h minus 1
places and start my comparisons from
there
okay so it sounds like a good heuristic
sounds like a good thing to do why does
it give us linear time well as I was
saying in the naive approach here the
left finger always moves left to right
right finger jumps all over the place
but every time we have one of these
speedups both fingers that the left
finger as well as the right finger can
move ahead H by the left finger in
particular can move ahead H minus one
spots before it starts doing comparisons
again so the the progress that my left
finger makes is proportional to the
number of matches I had before plus the
number of iterations number of
iterations is just the length of the
string and there we have linear time for
building the H values and therefore
linear time for building LCP ok I have a
video of this as I mentioning we're at
the end of it I say I've taught this
about four times and each time I think
it's going to be a lot easier than it
came out to be and now actually this is
probably the eighth time I've thought
this and I'll say the same thing this is
supposed to be one of those oh that's
one of those cute little ideas you go
from the obvious n square time algorithm
down to something that's linear time
just by this little little observation
on this tree ok everybody will get this
in the privacy of their own mind but now
to move on to the next lecture ok
burrows-wheeler ok how many people here
came to see burrows-wheeler
let's see really full screen mode so
burles well how many people have never
heard of Brewers wheeler no but nobody
okay one person who claims to do this
you what how many people have heard of
it that's good you add those two
together you more or less get everybody
okay so this is one of those things that
is running around a lot and people are
using it especially in computational
biology bioinformatics I don't fully
know why I agreed to talk about this in
order to learn all of those things okay
now dick car by saying this earlier to
carp in his 80th birthday celebration
was talking about being asked to give a
lecture on the PCP theorem which was
written up in the New York Times is the
most profound through man all of
computer science and but he actually
didn't understand it so he spent the
night before cramming to try to
understand enough to be able to give
this lecture so I figured well if the
car can do that then I can do that too
so anyway the borough of newly
transformed is something that's used in
data in compression levels that we
talked about earlier this is something
else that's used in compression it it's
old I don't know what it when I was
reverse originated but it was actually
not well known until more recently maybe
10 years ago or so and I we had a
visitor from Poland in in my department
but I don't know 15 years ago or
something anyway while he was at Davis
he was writing a book on data
compression and it was all information
through radicans very very deep in
mathematical and he presented to me on
this day he was leaving and I said oh
boy I can read this link and finally
understand burrows-wheeler because i
know that's very important and data
compression you'd never heard of it so I
felt like oh my god this this is you
know the major thing this is the crisper
of data compression
he hadn't heard of it yet his book is
just coming out and what a shame okay so
I'm trying to stall here alright so let
me try to tell you what I do understand
about about this and then just inspired
by what Pavel is going to be doing we
could have a flipped all of you who are
ready to talk about it and educate me
okay so give us string s length n the
burrows-wheeler transform is a
particular permutation of s plus one
more symbol not very compressed if you
have to have all the symbols in s plus
something now what is that actual
permutation you consider all the
rotations of s so you've got the string
s and you rotate it by one position
rotate it by two positions and so on so
you have n rotations and so imagine each
of those you generated each of those and
now you sort them lexicographically into
a matrix m okay and then the
burrows-wheeler transform of string s is
the string consisting of the last
character from each string and m going
top to bottom okay let me let me give
you actual picture for this will come
back to here so if my string is
Mississippi with a dollar sign at the
end then I'm going to consider all of
the rotations of Mississippi with a
dollar sign and I'm going to sort those
lexicographically and remember s a
dollar sign is the lex graphic smallest
character so this is Lex graphically
smallest and then this is the
lexicographic the next lexicographically
smallest and so on all the way down here
I look at the last character on this
listing it's ipss and it didn't come out
here but that that list ipss and that
string which is formed from the last
character of each one of those strings
each one of those rotations is the
burrows-wheeler transform of my ass
it's a permutation obviously of of the
characters in in the initial string okay
so this is a very close relationship to
suffix arrays these are these are the
rotations of the string sorted
lexicographically the suffix array shows
you for each suffix of the string how
they're ordered lexicographically okay
when I do a rotation of a string it the
rotation starts with a suffix of the
string and proceeds with the prefix of
the string that that actually came up in
one of the earlier lectures and just put
that out again now there are a couple of
pictures in dealing with this stuff that
are critical for least for me to keeping
my my sanity in all of this so here's s
and rotation one of the rotations would
have y and z it would have Y followed by
Z that's a rotation of s okay so this is
a suffix
s okay so when I do the rotation this
suffix is now in the in the start and
the prefix okay so if I'm looking at all
the rotations and I'm listing them
lexicographically what wonderful
coincidence occurs okay well as I said
the the rotation starts with the suffix
of the original string okay all the
suffixes are different lengths you don't
have ties between the lexicographic
order of two different suffixes they've
got to be different because the lengths
are different if only because of that so
there's a strict ordering of the
suffixes of the string so there's a
strict ordering of the rotations of the
string and what amazing coincidence
happens between those two orderings it's
the same okay it's absolutely the same
all right so and therefore and then
this is the shift okay what is this what
is the last character in this rotation
so is I'm going to call these things
rotations okay so we have s and we have
rotations of s that are in capital m
okay what is the last character here it
is this was a this went this way and
this way so that's character over here
right ok so the character if this shift
sorry if this rotation is actually got
equal to this suffix put in front
followed by that prefix then the
character here is the character here
okay and if the ordering of the strings
in the suffix in M which we're using to
define burrows-wheeler is the same as
the ordering of the suffixes in the
suffix array then what is this character
they this is the character just before
the suffix that starts here so I can
this is at position 12 the first suffix
is at position 12 so that starts a
position 12 the character just before it
is a position 11 and that's I well there
it is in the last position okay I come
down to here this is that's interesting
let's say this one this is yeah this is
this is starts at position nine this
particular this is a shift this is a
this is a road this is a circular shift
which puts a suffix of s in first
position in terms of suffolk's arrays
there and so this should be the eighth
character in the actual string so 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 proof by example okay so I'm
trying to motivate this notation up here
that I can find what character is in the
case position of birds wheeler transform
and it's also sometimes called lfk by
looking at the cave entry of the suffix
array that's it the Kate entry of the
suffix raz is a position in in the
string s subtract 1 which means look one
place to its left and take whatever that
character is in the NS okay so all I'm
trying to do is say you can build the
burrows-wheeler transform obviously in
linear time from a suffix array you can
actually go the other way with as well
you think about it's a little more
difficult it's a homework question but
so that this there's grateful so this is
my first meta question which I always
have come up with when there's a very
large literature now built on
burrows-wheeler transform what advantage
does it have over suffix array since the
two are equivalent well we'll get to
that well not space because actually the
suffix array should have mentioned here
we put a dollar sign in the suffix array
we wouldn't necessarily have that the
Isetta suffix burrows-wheeler transform
is a permutation of the original string
plus one more symbol well what the one
more symbol is is either a dollar sign
at the end or you can note which of
these rotations is the null rotation
there's the originals the original
string
some signal vs. and go get in for each
I'll have to talk about that it looks to
me at least at this level at this moment
I without telling you anything more a
suffix ray actually is one fewer
character than that a burrows-wheeler
strangle because the boro really string
will either have a fixed an extra dollar
sign or it has a pointer which tells you
where the null rotation is and why we
have those I'll get to in a minute okay
so the key observation this isn't seeing
the relationship between suffix arrays
and burrows-wheeler transform this tells
you how you can build the
burrows-wheeler transform quickly if a
string s prime oh okay sorry i have to
back up one thing now since yeah these
are our ordered lexicographically but
these are the rotations and they're
ordered lexicographically obviously all
the character all those the rotations
that begin with the Lex graphically
smallest character come together in one
section well there's only one of them
since as a dollar sign but the next Lex
graphically smallest character is I and
all of those rotations come together or
in one section so this is the I section
this is a dollar sign section this is
the M section p section and s section
and you can see they all start with s
these I'll start with P and so on so you
can the rotations divided into these
sections everybody with me on that
that's key alright if a string s prime
is the cave entry in the section for
letter c c is now a variable not the
actual letter C then the left shift of s
prime moving it over by one rotating
that way will be the case string ending
with letter C in the entire list
okay so let's just look at this one this
is the second string really tempted to
use this on here but it and amazing
after two years nobody seems to have
done that this is the this is the second
string in the section four letter s okay
so I claim that the left rotation of
this which is the string is si ppi
dollar sign mi SS should be the second
string in EM that ends with us okay well
where is this well where is the second
string that ends in here okay which as I
said was won over okay now I'll give you
a little argument for that maybe I
should give you that argument right now
this is and I said the first time I'm
teaching this so
yeah here's the key observation this is
just restating it okay if rotation s
prime is the case entry in the section
for letter C then the left shift call it
s double prime will be the case string
ending with letter C in em in the entire
thing alright so forget this pointer for
a moment why all right so here we are in
this is m and here see okay and you have
a string here which is the case entry in
this section okay all of these strings
in here begin with a C so this is a
c-section so they all begin with see and
when you do a left rotation they all end
with see okay now ending with C say
that's where this guy went to this one
when you two left rotation ends with C
and it's somewhere that rotation is
somewhere in the list ok now who's a
who's above it here these are strings
that also begin with C but they're
lexicographically smaller than this one
okay so since they agree on see the part
that makes them Lex graphically smaller
must be the remainder so when you do the
ship the left shift each one of these
guys this is going to be the start of
some string and it's it's going to be
Lex graphically smaller than the left
the left shift of this is going to be
lexicographically smaller than the left
shift of this so this one is going to
come somewhere above it now the c
section talks about what they begin with
so these shifts they don't have to be in
the same sections at all but anything
that any string that was above the cave
position in the c section will be above
the left rotation left shift of this
string its left this left shift will be
above this left shift okay so all of
those and we're restricting attention to
all of the strings that end with see
well string who's left shift ends with
see means if you went it came from a
string that began with c
so the only ones that are above the left
shift that end with sea of the ones that
came from here so if you're the cave
entry in c-section you are the case your
left rotation left shift you are the
cave occurrence of an M of a string that
ends with see okay now this is just
saying the same thing okay this is just
writing up what I just said but and
again you can observe this you can
observe this in here this is one of the
keys for inverting the burrows-wheeler
transform okay why did so I said the
burrows-wheeler transform is a
permutation of these characters
permutation of the string plus one more
symbol either a dollar sign that you put
at the end or a pointer which shows you
where the the beginning where the null
shift is probably other kinds of things
would work as well because then the
burrows-wheeler transform is invertible
you can go backwards from this string
which is IPS etc member the
burrows-wheeler transform string is just
the last character here this is all
conceptual this is so we can understand
what's going on and this tells you you
don't have to actually generate all
these sequences and and and sort them
because you can get the last character
here from the suffix array okay but we
want to go backwards we have this
burrows-wheeler transform string and we
want to go backwards okay so there are
various ways of doing this the classical
way that's described in the literature
is not obvious that it can be done in a
linear time so I don't like it but
it should be let's try to use this to do
the inversion so let's say I have a
pointer which is here okay so this is
the pointer to the null rotation and oh
by the way it since i since every
character shows up in the
burrows-wheeler transform why is that
we're rotating we all that we have all
the different rotations rotation of 0r
addition of one rotation of two and so
on and then we're looking at the last
character so obviously now all of the
characters of s of the initial string
show up in the burrows-wheeler transform
string so we can go through there we can
count how many a's let's say they do the
string the symbol this Lex graphically
smallest and then how many bees looks
graphically smallest and so on so we can
we can generate these spaces we know how
big each one of these sections are and
what section it is it's the dollar sign
section the I section the m section even
without having anything in here well
except for the we have that because
that's the the BWT string okay everybody
within ok so we point to where this the
null shift is and we know what section
we're in and that tells us what the
first letter of our original string is
yeah if you only have the last caller
that's why saying we do from counts okay
so the last column has every character
in the in the original string so we can
go through that and count how many eyes
do we have how many peas do we have how
many animals do we have but
no well we're just going to we're just
going to if we find out that we have but
we only have one dollar sign so the
first section is that big then we find
out we have four eyes so that occupies
the next four positions and so we know
that all the rotations that begin with I
will be located here even if we don't
know what the original string is okay so
we know the size we know the sizes of
all these sections and what is the first
character in that section yeah or
something you know that there's going to
be four eyes yeah okay only I think
about the inversion is a kind of a
puzzle but yeah all right so we have a
player to the start so we know that our
original string begins with this
character m okay now I want to get the
second character okay where is the
second character the second character is
the first character of the left shift of
this ok this is this well it's dollar
sign here yeah this should tell you
where the second character is ok so if
characters yeah so so this is the first
character in the section for EM okay so
it's right shift should be the first
position of the section for dollar sign
that's what the cells right okay if s
prime which is this thing now is the
kaif entry it's now the first entry in
the section for letter C which is now is
now am sorry then the left shift of s
prime will be the cave first string
ending with the letter C
oh yeah yeah well let letter C as the is
M okay so then we go to the I can't I
can't do different I came to an example
in in real time at this point in my day
ends with everything that's the one
above it okay so you're agreeing that
this is right okay and that's the shift
and you just keep doing it right because
now you you shifted in you now you know
what section you're in see you now you
know what the beginning of that was so
after dollar sign so after em we have I
yeah as I said after three hours of
doing this I can't do an example
real-time this is what keeps your sanity
okay so and this tells you how to get
each successive character alright so
let's say let's say we've learned mi SS
okay so you know mi SS so the rest is mi
SS I PPI right now na ssis SI ppi
mis-selling is the case that's the third
entry in the section 4c which is I then
the left shift of s prime will be the
cave third ending with letter C ending
with letter I ending with letter I so we
have to find the third one that ends
with letter I 123 and yes that is one
shift over okay so you just keep
applying this observation and you can
read out what the original string is
this is very I find it's very confusing
you just have to it's best if you do it
when you're very rested and
there are other ways of doing this this
one you can implement in linear time and
we have pointers which this is my these
are the strings and this is the case in
Section C we said one shift it should be
the case when that ends in C wherever
that happens to be and we'll put a
pointer from this string to this string
this is this one shift another way
thinking of this is this is a pointer
from the string to one left shift over
okay but that's what we're chasing these
pointers in doing this and doing this so
when you if you built these pointers
then you can just run along them and
collect the you do the conversion that
way and they have the classic way of
doing this has to do with radix sort but
this is easy to implement in linear time
here's an even easier way of doing this
but I was too jet-lagged coming all the
way from Davis to confirm this just
before the talk when I was trying to
think it through but I think this is
right this is this is contributed by a
graduate student the last time I taught
this were the only previous time that I
thought burrows-wheeler I gave as a
homework exercise how to do the
inversions and some students came up
with this algorithm some students came
up with the riddick sorting algorithm
Julia motsi ever came up with a clever I
think algorithm and you have to tell me
whether it works so
said you just go down the
burrows-wheeler string and you form a
two character string which is going to
be the character in the burrows-wheeler
plus its position in in the string so we
have I one and then we have p 2 and s 3
S 4 whatever that happens to be m 5 and
so on so you have these two character
strings then radix sort okay radix sort
those and pay attention to where
everybody went basically you'll have
some new ordering of these and then put
a pointer from where it went from an in
this in this list to where it went into
the radix sorted list and i know that
when she had that it was a couple years
ago looked at so to have this that's
great is then it makes it trivial that
this can be done linear time and at that
point I was younger I had a brain and it
wasn't after three hours of lecturing
and I could see that it was right and
Pavel just nodded that it was right so
must be okay I feel why tipico way to
presented he doesn't appear to be linear
I saw well I don't know when when I
looked at they won't look at the classic
way that's in a lot of the books it
didn't look on the face of it linear
time without additional data structures
it was just harder to argue that you can
actually do it linear time this way but
this one is is clear because these guys
are just constant space okay so that's
the inversion now I've got two minutes
to tell you why we care why do we care
about burrows-wheeler I mean I have to
tell you that I first learned about
burrows-wheeler from Steve scana we were
in a train going from Lyon to Paris
and he posed it as a puzzle at that
point it was just a puzzle how do you do
this and it was invented years ago and
it was a sort of a puzzle what it tends
to do this is the claim what it tends to
do is group together common characters
equal characters okay so if you have as
you do in DNA or in genomic sequences a
lot of repeated substrings ok well the
suffix array actually groups the first
character of those near each other
because those repeated carrick those
repeated substrings are equal for a
while this the burrows-wheeler tends to
group together the characters that are
not necessarily at the beginning of
those repeated substrings the ones that
are identical it's positioned to and in
position three and so on that's another
one of those things that I was going to
really be clear on before this lecture
but again after three hours of lecturing
it's just not clear to me anymore it was
last night it was absolutely clear so
clear I didn't have to write it down so
you want to think about that but the
claim is that the burrows-wheeler
transform which is invertible puts more
care identical characters together than
in the original string if there's highly
repetitive substrings as there are DNA
as there isn't doing and therefore you
can do a number of different compression
techniques the most obvious one is run
length encoding so you have a string and
it has 26 ends in a row you can replace
that by the number 26 and n and the
original paper by the way this this
pointer here I would call an FL pointer
in the original paper they call it an LF
pointer it's just they do the reverse
myths you know these we're pairing up
entries here and whichever way you want
to direct that and then this
this became an FM so if you've seen
papers that talk about using the FM
indexes that's all this is they're using
these pointers or directed the other way
YFM this is the name of the authors I've
forgotten what they are two Italians
yeah what Ron said and so that became in
honor of their and in their original
paper they have a lot of different ideas
for how you compress the burrows-wheeler
string so the most obvious one is run
length encoding because you're going to
have a lot of characters that are
identical together and another one has
moved to front which also seemed when I
understood it seemed to have some effect
but it seems to have dropped out of the
literature so I guess people have found
that that wasn't so successful and so
the point is that you can compress
burrows-wheeler string much better than
you can compress the original string and
it's invertible okay and so what I was
going to do next we run out of time is
show you how you search in a
burrows-wheeler string so you you have
the burrows-wheeler string which is a
representation of the original
Mississippi and I want to find all the
occurrences of ISS I ok but I no longer
have the original here of course I could
I could just invert and then search on
there but the whole key is how do i how
do i search in the burrows-wheeler
string which really means how do i
search in the compressed version of
burrows-wheeler well I've got to
uncompress little bits at a time as I'm
going but if I told you the logic of how
you search for a substring it's a
substring of the original s but we're
going to search for it in the
burrows-wheeler string then you can
figure out yourself how you're going to
open the compression as you as you need
to so
what's the whole point of this is you
get good compression of the DNA which in
our community why we've done this and
you can search inside that compressed
string for substrings just as fast at
least worst-case time as if you had the
original string itself and you don't
have to uncompress the whole thing now
the key to searching I really run out of
time so and this works out really well
because I didn't out of time in my
preparation to so the key to actually
how you search for a pattern in
burrows-wheeler is just these pointers
again these pointers tell you everything
so the the high-level idea is that
you're going to you have a pattern p
which is a B X Y Z or something you have
a last character here's the again the
partition I want to find the start
position and the end position a start
and an end position that contains all of
the substrings that begin with Z it's a
little confusing because we're going
last to first but now I'm talking about
beginning okay so they begin with Z well
that's just the Z section these are all
the strings that begin with Z okay and
then from that I want to find all the
the start and end positions of all the
strings that begin with YZ okay so what
does that mean that here are all the
strings that begin with Z where are all
the strings
begin with YZ there in the Y section
okay so these are strings that begin
with why some of those continue with Z
and some of them don't okay where's the
first one that continues with the Z its
River this guy pointed to so this is the
first string among the rotations that
begins with a Z so it is the
first whatever that mantra was you just
apply that you know that you're going to
be in the Y section but you have to
figure out where in the Y section you
are and that mantra tells you exactly
where that should be and you've already
have pointers that that did that for you
so you follow that point you get to
their you follow the next pointer and
that tells you the first position last
position symmetric and you end up with
the first and last positions in the NM
which means in the burrows-wheeler which
means in the suffix array of once you've
done all of those of this string this is
we find the first and last positions of
the strings in EM that begin with a B X
Y Z which means we found prefix of
suffixes that have that which means we
found occurrences this is very very
rough but again these pointers if you
understand the mantra then you
understand the pointers if you
understand the pointers then you'll
figure out the algorithm and that's
about all I know there is a book it's
very not well known i think there's
actually a whole book on burrows-wheeler
it was written a long time ago and i
don't know why it's not better cited in
this whole literature it's by the only
person I know in this is in 2008
Mukherjee at in Florida but they have
here the burrows-wheeler transform of
all of Shakespeare's Hamlet ok and a
little sex just a little section of it
and it's so it's got one two three four
five six lines long in here about 80
characters across and they're almost all
ends so it's just an illustration here
that even in English when you do the
burrows-wheeler transform of long enough
string you get a lot of grouping of
identical characters and then you do the
run-length encoding and you get
a compression I think I'm out of a time
right hmm yeah I've lost track I've
hyperventilated and I don't anybody ask
me anything yeah okay questions yeah so
the eternal my tuition for
burrows-wheeler transform was to
comprise the string yep but it's not
clear to be explicitly in application
let's say to match this compression is
used I when you look at bow tie yeah not
support I it's not immediately clear to
be wise it is even more exam yeah so
what is is it really used in DNA
application friend or so it's just this
is the multiple question you know they
don't have the microphones here don't
pick up the questions equal one question
is it really used seems to be there's
huge literature on everything is you
know you done on the burrows-wheeler
transform string and bowtie is a program
that is heavily used and does that and
there are about five or six papers that
I collected and I intended to read and
understand before this lecture on using
the Camaro's wheeler compressed strings
in sequence assembly in realignment all
the classical things that we do in
computational and sequence computational
biology on sequences there are papers
that show you how to do that using
Brewers wheeler and claiming that that
speeds things up by a hundred times
reduces space by a hundred times or
whatever and so that's that is the
reason if it's true if they're right and
I don't have any opinion about that yeah
this point of space
on what space oh yeah yeah yeah yeahs
for so if you're using the suffix array
you need log enemies for every entry of
your presentation okay you're using
Morse wheeler you need two beats for DNA
you just it's just a permutation of the
text so if the alphabet is small it's a
big say ah ok that's an interesting
point yeah I am this is a bit cheating
because the part that you didn't show
about looking for a match you need to
keep some of these pointers if you want
to do this official yeah otherwise you
find this segment but you don't know the
location ABX except yeah see that right
the fraction of the starting point yeah
yeah so there's lots of video a lot of
ensuring so Ron's major point here which
I had not thought of it as is sounds
like a good advertisement for brewers
wheeler is it in the suffix array we're
keeping numbers okay and what are those
numbers those are indices from position
1 through n so you need about log n bits
to represent them in the burrows-wheeler
transform we're just keeping characters
that come from DNA in our application so
we need two bets for alphabet of size 4
and so that's already a big big savings
there and then the additional
compressibility is the next
advertisement for for dealing with the
bruins wheeler transform strings
so the last column of the matrix isn't
available yeah I'll say any other
columns are they invertible oh okay
there are any other columns that are
invertible I'm not sure so in order to
invert in order to fully invert you need
either the dollar sign that helps
because that's always at the top since
the dollar sign is is the smallest or
you need a pointer which tells you where
you begin so I did think about what if
you don't have either you actually can
learn a circular you can learn the
string in circular order you just don't
happen to know where it begins so that
sort of is a hint that maybe you can get
a lot of other information as well but
anyway I have not thought that through
the first one yes you can get the first
one it's the text to me no sir first
column is ordering off so the first
column is us which was invertible yeah
okay got some but but the first one
tells oh no yeah if you had the actual
suffix array then it's yeah it's
invertible
well that's all I know about
burrows-wheeler it would be I was hoping
that there would be a true expert here
on burrows-wheeler who could truly
answer the question of why is everybody
talking about it and it's like I don't
know pet rocks or loops I never really
got into that but but I did like I like
those those those hoverboards I was
thinking of getting one of them but
apparently they blow up some anyway
thank you